hey guys I'm Ryan right so Jurassic
world is upon us so I thought I'd check
out the honest trailer for none other
than the lost world Jurassic Park dos
now Jurassic Park is [ __ ] ultimate I
love that movie so much the second one
was okay it was it was good but it could
have been better
yeah so I'm excited to see what honest
trailers that's the sacrum the director
who managed to avoid unnecessary sequels
up to this point comes a completely
unnecessary sequel only this time it's
the second time the lost world
Jurassic Park shouldn't that title be
the other way around
no okay and who loves Jurassic Park for
its all inspiring wonder subtle humor
and likable characters now get ready for
a generic run away from dinosaurs movie
with more deaths more dangling vehicles
and war giant practical t-rex heads
passing next to things
[Music]
pushing into things and moving behind
things because those heads cost a ton
and Spielberg is gonna get his money's
worth dammit that need a cast of humans
who still haven't learned one thing from
the first time about making the same
mistakes again you're making all new
ones featuring the return of your
favorite wisecracking side character
from Jurassic Park as a boring neurotic
dad that must have feelings come on
Chyna Sarah who's just there to rattle
off the trailer lines movies very angry
movie once and for all that a little
Goldblum goes a long way you know I have
to get used to dr. Malcolm he suffers
from a deplorable excessive personality
along for the ride is Ian's daughter
[Music]
a gymnast and total slob who is
personally responsible for the low point
of the franchise
okay second lowest point then get to
know Egan's paleontologist girlfriend
Sarah she's the worst watch is this
bumbling Miss Magoo
constantly harasses the dinosaurs steals
a baby t-rex that gets Tobi from the
west wing killed walks around with t-rex
blood on her jacket even though she's
supposed to know better
Tyrannosaurus got the large portion
alone factory cavity of any creature in
the fossil record and generally makes
life harder on everyone else around her
wait are we supposed to be rooting for
the dinosaurs or the people who stare
helplessly as the creatures were once
treated with reverence and restraint are
transformed into over-the-top killing
machines where the mighty t-rex becomes
a generic monster and the claustrophobic
Raptor kitchen scene from the first film
becomes Jurassic Benny Hill
[Music]
[Music]
so try to enjoy the ride then try to
enjoy the climax to the ride that feels
like it was bolted on from a different
movie as Spielberg runs out of things
for dinosaurs to do in the jungle and
ships went off to San Diego for a
20-minute Godzilla parity in an extended
dinosaur money shot that we all thought
had killed the franchise but we had no
idea what was coming story yes
Julianne lass Vince yawn Santa Claus
mckayla maroney
is not impressed Pete post but wait
postulate wait Postlethwaite II must go
at Kobayashi Oedipus Rex and a whale's
vagina to Jurassic to furious even a
will be bigger and better than Jurassic
Park I can't imagine anything being
bigger than that sure I see program but
I don't know yeah yep pretty much be
sure to subscribe for me never saw that
in your ears Wow normally I review these
videos but they literally said
everything that I feel about that movie
wow that is incredible incredible but
honestly like I agree with everything
they said but there's still a part of me
that because it's the Jurassic Park
world I still enjoy it like if I watch
part one I'm gonna be like we got to
watch part two now like I do still check
it out
I think there are some scenes that are
still really good did you like the scene
when they kidnapped the baby t-rex and
Mama t-rex is trying to get it back I
thought that was a pretty intense scene
I thought some of it was pretty fun
actually and whenever the dinosaurs were
like animatronics they that look scary
and the San Diego thing like was stupid
but I enjoyed it he's dumb but I had a
good time watching it was so out of
place
but like I said I enjoyed it anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
and
because if we get enough followers we
can get product placement people I'll
stink Renick hey my brother and I are
trying to start a YouTube channel called
bros react yay another reaction channel
just what we need and we are huge fans
we would really love if you could give
us a shoot out to give our channel some
hype thanks man
you are awesome keep up the great vids
yo guys check out bros react you know
what they do they do reaction videos
this is the hardest thing to do in the
world Austin I'm telling you right now
it's not easy being able to sit here and
watch a video and let your emotions just
take over that's hard work it's really
hard work you got to be able to feel
your feelings so seriously man come on
even I know you can be more creative
than reactions come on